you know like I'm Nickelodeon they slime
you you know that's a dream
yeah you're slime for 30 seconds and
that's mine I was slimed for 16 hours a
day for a month they were covering me
with blood every single day it felt like
loop that in red dice
I swear if it isn't dead if it ever
comes back we'll come back to those are
like seeing it with an audience and with
your fellow losers for the first time it
was great my my sisters we're talking
through the whole thing so yes they're
adding commentary like literally like
that that's exactly what they are
they're like oh no I guess that's kind
of what you want in our let me get very
interactive I got very emotional in the
last 20 minutes of the film I was trying
to stop yeah crying I was like I can't
be in the movie and be the most
emotional person in the cinema yeah now
how did the adult losers form their
bodice or something you guys did a head
of filming to kind of form that karaoke
Queen over here yeah I started a
whatsapp chat for us yeah
commanders whatsapp chat and then I'm
with you guys we need to go we need to
go out so we went out to dinner and then
we went drinks and dancing and then we
went to karaoke too so that was like it
was like no and we played ping pong it
was like yeah it was like a whole
journey and that was like we won there
was a karaoke booth at the premiere most
- I was afraid someone's gonna film it
on YouTube yeah it might be out there
I was in there and he pulled me in let's
see what's your go-to karaoke song I
don't have one that's the thing like I
just I do whatever is on the screen and
I just try to you're right you do you
get a lot of country actually it was a
Garth Brooks version of a kiss hardly I
do it duet with Andy that we've been
we've been karaoke since 2011 you don't
bring me flowers when I've had enough
tequila I'll do I was still in the role
of Ben you see so it was a little bit
Charlie yeah okay would you say in your
native accent or what you're saying as
Ben probably is big that's what I
would've been cool I'm gonna sing
everything with an American accent the
one who doesn't sound right yeah I want
to talk about a couple of specific
scenes specifically the buried alive
slash blood scene because I think the
thing that gave me the most fear in the
movie is just imagining you filming with
this like opaque thick liquid and being
completely submerged and being like how
do I get out what was that like crazy
because it's something you don't really
prepare for they built the tank and then
we did a rehearsal with water like the
day before so we could understand the
speed of how it would happen and all
that but after every take I have to get
cleaned up and then they'd also have to
drain the tank and clean it up the blood
before we could do another take so it
was a a long process and we wanted to
make sure that we were ready before take
one but it was it was gross it was super
gross and I thought it was gonna kind of
be like one day of gross Ness and then
we're on but if they were covering me
with love every single day like 16 hours
of you know I gotta make a living they
slime you you know that's a dream yeah
your slime for 30 seconds and that's
mine I was slimed for 16 hours
the day for a month yeah then six-day
weeks yeah
what are they make it out of these days
cuz you see it was like corn syrup when
it felt like Lube that in red dye that's
what it felt like and in fact it dyed my
hair that's what the cinematographer
said yeah yeah there would like chunks
because I was wearing it every single
day that died in the hair like I had
like big chunks of right he also had it
around your eyelids all the time oh man
it was like oh like but you never ever
got like like if you were got upset you
well if you did I'm good right but it
was but it was like but it was like
justified they're like you already were
in it you know I mean like you would
like come on guys let's go and when I
was growing because mostly crappy with
Andy does please shoot yeah I mean the
director really put you through your
paces every day and so the rest of the
losses were like okay we got to go to
that level yeah jess is taking the rock
yeah not like that but like we couldn't
complain about anything we were like
like like well we can play she's covered
in Lube
[Laughter]
you
[Music]